increases yeah right here increase
increase creativity yeah yeah oh yeah I
want to write something that'd be great
yeah strengthening to organs that's very
broad I like that heart liver lungs
right so stronger my organs are I don't
even know what they're like
I've never
I've never gotten my organs checked
when I wake up I go
but you're vibrant and you look
remarkable go ahead can you show me how
you're actually going to point your
[ __ ] to the Sun
and it's really funny that you say that
because what you're being is rude and
condescending and not even true these
boys know I'll show you so where's the
Sun
sunset or Sunrise what's a more like
effective blast of vitamin D and what's
that high energy index okay High Noon
right there that's where the sun is no
no it's got to be high noon because they
said full blasting how about this can
the sun be there what that light is
works for me it works for me right so
should I demo right I can be the Sun for
you all right all right so stand for a
second and be the Sun right so
you're the son right there okay yeah
just you give me raise right so I'm
gonna be like
oh
well I should talk in the mic to stay
there Oh what a beautiful sunny day what
should I do today go to the parking nah
um hiking no wait a second get creative
my butthole right so then I'll go
Sun's there and I'll just kind of go
like this right
[ __ ] you're actually doing oh whoa whoa
didn't know I thought that was happening
yeah I thought we were doing this I'm
staring dude you can't pull your dick
out and not expect me to stare dude I'm
getting kind of horny legit I'm Legit
horny it's not hitting this it's not
Bobby you got a nice [ __ ] bro
wait how is your [ __ ] so nice you
know what I mean dude you have like one
of the nicest apples
so that's in your [ __ ] face no three
seconds you'd be you'd be the last in
that position I can last there for one
hour right now if you give me a hundred
dollars yeah go ahead
why a hundred dollars it's more than
that I'll just
you did that for an hour
that's a downward dog for an hour Bobby
one-handed
wrestler look at that head stability oh
you know what we can put the butt tape
it it it's a tape that opens up your
[ __ ] it used to be one of our
sponsors oh really we could get that my
point is that I can do go ahead yeah can
I press pause real quick I just wanna
say this sincerely
don't make me cry no honestly I I think
I know where the direction you're going
it might go there I know I know but
let's just I wanna I'm gonna accept it
from you but let me just let me just get
in the moment lock eyes with you and
then really just retain you know what I
mean and really be here for that yeah
I'll save the the
cheaper compliments for the end but okay
it meant so much to me for you to just
pull your dick out in your [ __ ] out
because we were nervous and now I feel
so much more at ease and I feel so much
more connected to you after you pulled
all that out so thank you for flashing
[ __ ] and b-hole because it really did
make me feel just safe so thank you okay
and you do have a beautiful butthole
like your butthole is really nice man
it's not a lot of hair there's none it's
a miracle it's incredible any poo
residue no it had like a nice coloration
to it it was really lovely dude do you
have a day I do a day